underpriced attention in 1998 was email
how many people here have done email
marketing in their careers close enough
to it that they could have a sense
reason hi I just want to get a set good
so this will make a lot of sense for a
lot of people in 1999 I had an email
newsletter that had 200 000 people on it
that had 90 open rates
so for the people that don't follow
email you're crushing it today with 30
open rates meaning you've sent an email
30 of them actually open it and then
there's a whole other thing do people
even act on it in 1998 I had 90 of the
people opening the email because in 1998
we hadn't ruined email yet
right you didn't get all the spam you've
got in the last 25 years we were opening
it and I realized very quickly Direct
Mail was working for me but email was
free that's the underpriced attention of
1998 having a website doing email and
then finally the day Google AdWords came
out I bought up every wine term you can
imagine for six months there it wasn't
even 10 cents a click floor it was five
cents a click and I crushed and so in a
very short period of time with
absolutely no money
with no money I was able to grow a very
large business and it became the
foundation of how I think
sit here today the following platforms
are completely underpriced in both their
organic reach and their paid media
Facebook
Twitter
Snapchat
Instagram
tick tock
YouTube
LinkedIn this is profound all of the
platforms
are underpriced
under organic reach and their media what
does this mean how many people here have
now gone viral on Tick Tock you posted
something and it got a million views
raise your hand raise it
for the Seven Ten people here that raise
their hand
they felt the impact of underpriced
organic they posted something they had
20 followers a hundred followers a
thousand followers they posted something
and they got a million views
that is an enormously important thing
for this room to talk about
in the history
of marketing
that was never possible you did not buy
a full page ad in the newspaper you did
not buy AdWords on Google you did not
buy a television ad on television and
they just miraculously
gave you unlimited more awareness for
more than you paid for
they didn't just give you 55 newspaper
ads because you paid for one they give
you one
this is why this is so important a lot
of you including myself grew up in Era
where you would amass followers and you
would post
and you would get a percentage of those
followers to see it it was small more
email marketing than it was social
we are now in the post tick tock
application of social media
where you can absolutely get way more
exposure than you've earned because you
don't have to build a list or a
community you just have to make
individual pieces of content strong
everybody in our company is obsessed
with Pac platforms and culture what does
that mean it means that every single
person in our agency has to know what
every platform is doing every day we
have literally hundreds and hundreds of
people every day obsessed about every
single thing every platform is doing at
the moment and then an entire different
group
yeah one in the same sometimes if they
have enough Talent that's paying
attention to culture which rappers which
athletes which soda which fashion brand
which everything what is happening in
culture and not just youth culture what
are moms in Indonesia care about what
are people in Afghanistan consuming like
literally Global Information on both
platform and culture and once that is at
your obsession and your ideas
come from the framework of pack
your ideas will do better you will get
more Quant and quality back from that
and that will create a collective wisdom
of what you should be doing or what is
touching the hearts and the minds
because the only way someone does
something votes for someone buys
something goes somewhere is when that
thing hits someone's relevance inside of
them and led them to consider
something marketing hasn't changed in a
long time
the mediums and the creative strategies
change
and the industry is holding on to
yesterday for dear life
and I am intrigued by tomorrow
I'm intrigued by tomorrow this industry
is obsessed with yesterday but I and my
companies we [__] dominate today
tomorrow is interesting and we'll keep
an eye on it because it's coming
yesterday is a nice romantic story but
it's the easiest waste of money of all
time it's today that we focus on and
that I think that's what everybody
should be focusing on
[Music]
thank you